[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
had to raise her siblings and now that
she's older she just wants to be their
friend
we also talk to a woman whose husband is
trying to live his failed athletic
career out through their kids
it's causing a lot of problems at home
stay tuned
[Music]
what up what
up is the dr john deloney show i'm john
just like my mom and namie and i hope
you're doing well
today's show we're going to talk about
relationships mental health whatever i
don't know whatever people call with
that's what we're talking about if you
want to be on the show
join the dozens who listen just kidding
james we got millions of people this is
getting bananas
b-a-n-a-n-a-s but you want to be on the
show go to johndalone.com
ask ask fill out the form it goes to
kelly and she creates these shows and
she gives you a shout and then you and i
chit chat and it's a blast or you can
call 1-844-693-3291
and listen i've been asking for this for
like a year and now they're starting to
roll in and i'm excited about this and i
hope you will consider this
if you've been on the show before
i love these follow-up emails to let me
know how things are going
was my recommendations terrible how did
my advice work in your life when you
actually tried it in real life um
people are writing back and it's
incredible i love it so at the end of
today's show i want to talk through a
follow-up here's a follow-up email from
mary from tyler whose husband
continuously was cheating on her we got
some follow-up here it's fantastic and
so man so excited let's go to marina in
waterloo
where napoleon may be buried what's up
marina
not much how are you good sorry we had
to do a bunch of uh intros over again
because i'm terrible at this job how are
you
i'm doing okay excellent excellent so
what's going on
so i need to figure out how to be a big
sister and not a parent to my younger
siblings
now that we are all adults yes so tell
me about
how did you get stuck in that role as a
kid
um
well in
2004 my dad deployed overseas i was
about 11
then and i have five younger siblings
and
after that he was just kind of in and
out so
my mom switched to basically a single
parent who was at work most of the time
so it kind of fell on me to make sure
that
the kids homework was done they were fed
they were up in time for school chores
got done all that kind of stuff
did was that ever discussed or did that
just fall on you
it
i just kind of assumed the
responsibility because it felt like if i
didn't then nobody would
can i just tell you i'm sorry that was
your childhood
me too i'm sorry
i mean i
i'm grateful for your old man service
that's awesome and
i'm confident your mom was doing what
she could to keep things going and i'm
sorry that that fell on you it wasn't a
child's job to raise five kids
yeah
so how old are you now
28 28 how old is your youngest sibling
20.
oh gosh there was six of y'all in a span
of eight years
yes holy moly
wow
that's a lot of humans in a short amount
of time
are they all biological kids
yes
wow
okay
so there's six of y'all
tell me what you're struggling with now
um
i just kind of want to be i think the
relationships i struggle with most is my
youngest two brothers they're number
four and number five okay an order and i
want to be like a safe place for them
not somebody that they're worried about
disappointing or
judging them for
the stumbles they have through life
yeah do you all live by each other
you're all scattered across yeah we're
all within like 45 minutes of each other
that's fantastic so what's your
relationship like with your mom and dad
now
uh i don't talk to my dad and
my relationship with my mom goes from
rocky to okay back and forth okay
why don't you talk to your dad
um he
moved and decided that he didn't want to
talk to any of his children anymore
and then
uh struggles with
a drug addiction so we kind of
me and my husband decided it wasn't
safe to try and pull him back in with
our young kids so yeah tell me about
your your house you got little ones
yes i have a eight-year-old a
six-year-old and a four-year-old
dude you're you're repeating the process
huh
yeah if you hustle if you hustle you can
have two more so you can have no no i
was done having kids at 23. so
oh man
so
what you experienced as a young kid
i'm going to classify as trauma is a lot
and my guess is your mom was going
through a lot your dad was going through
a lot
and you experienced trauma and you've
got some open-ended relationships that
should be closed-ended relationships
meaning your mom and dad have never been
a safe place to anchor
into no which has left you untethered
through your whole life
what was what was some of your coping
strategies into your late teens early
20s or you got married early
yeah i got married in 2015.
uh my oldest is not my husband's child
well she's been adopted now but
so i had that struggle and so did you
have some adventure years
uh not really okay you went from when i
got pregnant at 19 so okay okay went
from being a parent to my siblings to
being a parent to my kid wow
so i wrote down here while you were
talking just on my little notepad here
that you've got to reclaim your
childhood
and i know you're 28 and you feel like
you're 100 years old because you've
lived 100 years
but you're still in your 20s and so as
an old man i want to tell you and i'm
not really an old man but just older
than you
you're just a kid and i want you to
reclaim your childhood so what does that
mean when you've got three kids a
husband you got responsibilities you got
mouths to feed
when's the last time you laughed so hard
diet coke came out your nose
uh
never right
when's the last
like
super
romantic
smoking hot weekend away you and your
husband have had
we've only done like two overnights
since we've had kids away from them yeah
when's the last time you ate and then
you ordered dessert and you just ordered
a second one just cuz
never right
so there's a little girl in there
that is dying to laugh real real hard
and when i say dying i'm i mean that
and there's a
lovely
sexy
connected
24 year old in there
that looks at that husband and goes
she's in there too
and there's a 16 year old and a 19 year
old and a 24 year old and a 28 year old
that would love just to dance in the
living room
and i want you to discover her
because she's in there
and what i want you to start
allowing into your life something you've
never allowed in there before
because you've been an adult since you
were 10
is joy
laughter
desire
rambunctious sex with your husband
more laughter
eating healthy most of the time and just
eating garbage once a week just to be
silly
and here's where that loops back to your
original let me just stop there how does
that sound does that sound like madness
or does that sound awesome like when i
say that what it sounds
great but i don't know how to get there
because i'm always
so
worried about like what needs to be done
and needs to be taken care of yeah i
don't know how to
like let go of that
and it's not going to be an either or
it's going to be both because your kids
still got to eat and they still got to
go to bed at night
the way it works
is you were born into a story
which is your job is to start parenting
at 10.
you are told a story about here's what
your value is your value is to make sure
everybody else is okay
your value is you take your laughter and
shove it down you take your sexuality
and shove it down you take your fill in
the blank and shove it down
that little girl who just wants to dance
around the living room to
old hip-hop she needs to be quiet
because we got to get our homework done
that's the story you're born into and
what i want you to do is to imagine a
new story what would you write
what i want
i want to
feel better when i wake up in the
morning i want to have more sex i want
to have more laughter i want to start
dancing in my living room all these
whatever that looks like for you i want
to start horse riding lessons i don't
know what it is you can become a jiu
jitsu practitioner
but i want you to go out with your
husband get a
babysitter
get somebody in your neighborhood or get
one of your siblings to watch your kids
and i want you all to go out
and create something incredible it could
be whatever you want it to be
and then what you're going to do is
you're going to this is the magic word
that i want you to keep in your mind
you're going to practice
because it's all going to feel weird
and it's going to feel like you're
violating some sort of value system it's
going to feel awkward
i don't know how to dance i don't know
how to laugh really loud
i don't have to be quiet because i want
to wake a baby up
i don't know how to just get a
babysitter and go with my husband and
have a great weekend away two weeks away
where we don't think about our eight and
our six and our four-year-old because
they're taken care of
you have to practice those things
and you're going to fail at some of them
and you're going to get tired at some of
them and you're not going to work at
some of them and that's okay
to be curious about it when you practice
why didn't that work this time let's try
it again last time here's what i'm
getting at
i don't want you to wake up and be 50
and realize that you never laughed hard
i want you to have joy in your life and
it was taken from you at a young age
now ask to answer your original question
with your brothers and sisters
i want you to call it out
call a meeting
take everybody to the cracker barrel
whatever it happens to be
and say from this point forward i'm your
sister i'm not your mom that's my job
and we're gonna be silly
and i'm gonna go first
and so you're gonna have to go first and
lead the relational change
but i want you to speak out loud what
you want it to look like so speak it out
loud what do you want it to look like
i just want to be able to get together
with them and have fun and not all be so
drowning in
our past that we can't have a good time
together so what is wearing what does
fun look like
being ridiculous i know but what does
that look like
just having a barbecue and playing
cornhole and throwing water balloons at
each other
yeah
okay i want you to set that up
and when you set that up i want you to
make a few rules we are not allowed to
talk about dad we're not talking about
mom
this is just kids having fun
and you can call it sunday fun day and
once a month have all your brothers and
sisters over to your house just to be
chaotic
and be silly and just we're just gonna
have moon pies and marshmallows and
whatever i'm gonna call it diabetes i
don't care what you do but
set it up
and live it
and it's gonna again this can be
something you practice because there's
gonna be some moments where
your brothers and sisters don't know how
to be safe either they don't have to
feel safe you don't know how to feel
yeah
and so y'all gonna have to practice
feeling safe what's it like to go over
to big sister's house
have barbecue have a cheap burger
and play corn hole and sit outside and
drink cheap beer and then just go home
like we don't
there's no fights there was no
discussions no whatevers like what is
that like
you have to practice it
but here's what i think
i think if you set the stage they would
love a big sister and they would love a
friend and they would love somebody they
can lean into but isn't gonna lecture
them when they start doing stupid stuff
that 21 year olds do
yeah
and we're all going to watch the latest
whatever movie that's coming out we're
all going
and everybody pay their own way i'm not
paying for everybody i don't make that
kind of money but we're all going except
for you tom you got to stay and keep all
the kids like whatever
that's big sister stuff but i want you
to just to visualize it and write it
down and go i want you to stay away from
words like i just want to have fun
i just want to be ridiculous i want you
to be really specific because if you
just say i just want to have fun that
bar tends to move on us as we're as
we're sitting there
like we could be having more fun we
should have a pool we should have done
like i my picture is we're all sitting
in lunches around the fire pit eating
hot dogs i'm gonna make that picture
happen you got what i'm saying yeah
do you think you're worth that
sometimes
i want to tell you you're worth that all
the time
you knew who else was worth that
those three little kids
because you know who hurt a lot too your
mom
yeah
and you absorbed her tension
you absorbed her
lack of
self-respect you absorbed her marital
challenges and i don't want that for you
and i don't want that for your kids
i want them to think back my mom was
bonkers she was hilarious she was always
turning all the lights off and playing
hide and seek in the house
she was building giant pillow forts with
us she was always telling us to leave
and then she turned on this really
swanky dance music and she would lock
the door with that in there i don't know
what they were doing but it makes me
have the heebie-jeebies like
whatever it is
i want those to be the memories of your
mom i mean if your kid's memories of you
is that fair
yeah would your husband lean into that
with you
yeah he's super goofy
excellent live into the goofy
but my the big takeaway here is you got
to go first and lead by example with
your siblings
you have to be really intentional very
clear about what you want to do and then
i want you to go make it happen and be
really graceful with yourself because
it's going to be awkward and weird you
have to practice it the whole way
and you
are
worth it
oh my gosh you're worth it your
husband's worth that your kids are worth
it you are worth it so grateful for you
we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i got to
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to sarah
in san diego california what's up sarah
hi dr john how are you just rocking onto
the brick of dawn what about you
yeah doing well thank you so much for
having me on
course is it beautiful in san diego
yes very sunny and warm
so great
it's cold and gray here in nashville
it's still beautiful but man
or i think of san diego i just think of
everybody's smiling
yes
it's hard to be sad there
hey so what's up
well um i have a question so my husband
and i have been married for 13 years we
have two
amazing boys they're both they're nine
and 12 years old and um you and your
husband still like each other
we do yes most of the time
we've made it through a tough season but
you know yeah
whenever anyone says we've been married
13 years
and we've got two kids and our kids are
amazing
that gap is usually like kind of sucks
right now kind of sucks but it's cool
like that
well these are then three and four i
would say years old
all right so
y'all kind of like each other what's up
yeah uh so we're both former athletes
that's actually how we met and so our
sons are very involved in sports um
we've had him in sports you know a very
young age
uh my husband's a
dad coach i guess if you want to put him
in that caliber and um
over i guess the last couple years
things have gotten i would say pretty
intense with with like his involvement
in coaching and things like that and
um the closer that our oldest in
particular gets to high school um i just
feel like his the the intensity there uh
my husband's coaching and it they're
sometimes it just gets i think a little
bit over the top
um and i kind of want to know how to
navigate that because you know i i don't
want to get quote you know in the way i
guess of my husband and his coaching and
his intensity but
sometimes it's really i think just just
over the boundary um and just kind of an
example yeah give me an example yeah
yeah we were
just a couple weeks ago this is i guess
probably why it prompted my my question
but
uh we were driving home from not a game
a basketball game but a basketball
practice and
my husband was very disappointed with
the with the efforts given with you know
the outcome of the practice what not
and for
not even joking 50-minute car ride home
he yelled and screamed at like the top
of his lungs of just his
you know disgust his disappointment
and
in that moment i just was kind of like
you know wow this is really happening uh
i have to say something i didn't say
something in the car why not why not why
not why not why not
um why didn't you stop and say
nobody talks to my son like this stop
like what kept you from that
my husband's hard to approach um no no
no i i i'm talking about like if a
rabbit dog comes chasing after your son
you like
i know mama gets in between them
i don't care about like at that point
your husband's out of control he's a
lunatic yeah he's a child
what kept mama from getting between a
lunatic and her baby
are you unsafe
no
i don't i don't think i am do you ever
get that sort of treatment
know
sarah we've never we've never yelled and
screamed at each other but no he um
yeah and and i i think that's probably
why maybe i was very kicking back in
that moment like this what is going on
here because it's not a regular thing
well one i'm not always in the car with
them after practicing there you go it
does happen yep um but i was very like
taken aback by it and
have you talked since about it
yeah so
then that night he as soon as we got
home um he just he hit the showers like
he was just you could tell something was
going on he was you know he didn't talk
to anybody he just went house
i talked to the kids you know let them
know hey are you okay kind of checked in
with them and they were like that was
rough i don't know why and so okay let's
you know get to bed and dinner and all
those things
and i approached him he was you know in
our room kind of tv mode just you could
tell he was chilling out and the first
thing i asked him was are you okay
and he's like yeah cool i'm good okay
and i said you know
well what just happened in a car was
you know i'm not okay with what just
happened can we talk about it because
wow and he got really defensive and
um basically was like no i don't want to
talk about it tonight because nothing
good will come of it
and basically the next 24 hours was just
silent and that's that's kind of how he
gets when he's frustrated so i knew you
know um so the next night i approached
him again same thing kind of night time
boiling down it's calm he's been a
better mood and
and he acted like nothing had happened
he was just annoyed that i was even
asking him and bringing it up and
and i basically was like hey those are
my kids they're your kids but they're my
kids too and
i you know that was that was totally
over the line and i said i understand
that you
have you're very passionate about you
know their their efforts and you want to
see them do well i said i want to see
them do well too but
that was just i think more damaging and
more counterproductive than good and and
i had shared with him what the kids had
shared with me that night when we got
home and that they basically were like
that's not motivating my oldest needs
that he doesn't even necessarily want to
play basketball anymore
and he just kind of like wrote it off
like oh they're kids and they're going
to do that even if you ask them to do
chores they're just you know sensitive
so here's the thing
like if that's my kid the season's over
today
they're out
out and i'm a college athlete too
i trained with a professional mma team i
know about working really hard and i
know about coaches getting in my face i
know about coaches pushing me pushing me
and pushing me this is abuse
and you're going to create a you're
going to not create you're going to
further a generation of young
people
whose
relationship with their parents is
weaponized one from the one that's
that's hurting them and the other from
the parent that won't protect them
and
that sort of rage
that he's got pulsing through his veins
ends real bad at some point
you gotta stop
and the oh they're just kids that's not
true man
it's abusive it's absolutely stone
abusive
and here's the thing you know that right
yeah
like i can hear it in you that you know
it why do you feel powerless to say not
my kids
because if if an employee at mcdonald's
talk to your kids that way you'd walk
out of that restaurant
if a teacher talked to your kids that
way they would never go back to that
school
all right and so what makes it if
another coach talked to your kids that
way you'd be off that team so fast
and so my question like there's
something there's a safety issue here
i don't know what it is
either you've lived in this for so long
or it gets like yeah i like i trust you
it may be so shell-shocked
like it may be so what is happening to
the man i love
but your kids desperately need to get
get them away from this lunatic
he's got something going on in him that
is deep and full of rage
yeah
over a basketball practice why would you
yell at your kid over a basketball
practice
right right it's just
if you just say it out loud it's insane
and it's not about they need to learn
how to work hard yeah they need to learn
how to work hard in responsibility and
the best way a child can learn
responsibility is not by screaming at
them and turning them into
a
just setting off every fight or flight
alarm they have
uh dr nadine burkharis she's just as
she's a savant she's brilliant
she researches childhood trauma and
here's a an analogy she gives
she says our our fight-or-flight systems
are designed for when a bear shows up in
front of our cave
and then our bodies signal to take off
either we fight that bear we run from
that bear
we don't have biological systems for
what happens when that bear just decides
to live in that cave
or if every day we walk into our home
which should be our safe place
there's a bear there and that's what
your kids have
and so their bodies are eating
themselves from the inside out
and i think yours is too and my guess is
his is too
if you had to guess what's going on
inside of him you've known him for a
long time what is it
um
he
i believe he's
trying to live out his dream through our
kids for 100 percent
yeah and that but that
his desire to live out a dream means
he's not
loving his life right now
why not
what about his current life is no good
uh
that's a great question a question i've
been
wanting to know for a while
um
i i think you know
he well he's not happy where he is i
guess in life like he's with you with
his career with his two kids like what
i think i think with career in
particular i mean he's had a lot of um
uh he's an entrepreneur and he's had
just a lot of i think failures and
things in the last few years and
you have to get in line on that one man
there's millions of people right yeah
yeah right and you know i i think it's a
plethora he's
yeah it's it's hard to even just
pinpoint um because it's it's hard to
really talk to him it's hard to get you
know he doesn't like to share his
feelings
um it's just yeah he
it's it's it's a lot um
and so we're doing something i don't
like to do it's to talk about somebody
when they're not on the show
um when they're on the phone but here's
why i'm doing that
because you're
you've set sail
and here's where this goes
you either have to turn off
your maternal instinct to protect your
kids and let dad do what dad's gonna do
you set sail into another harbor to
protect yourself
and dads and boys do what dads and boys
do and again i'm not
please hear me say
i'm not for
letting kids sit around and play video
games and i'm not for letting
like weakness that's what i'm talking
about i'm talking about abuse
and
all right let me just i'll say like
i think you know this but your marriage
is in trouble am i right
yeah it's it's been quite serious yeah
there's been stuff for the last few
years for sure yes does he have somebody
else
uh he did okay do you
no
no
have y'all come back from that
uh
i think
not completely um
you know we were in counseling for like
a year
what went sideways with that
i just
i think he's
i don't know it's hard to say but
he has intensity with things when he's
in the moment when there's
it needs to be intense and then it just
kind of things fade
what kind of athlete was he
uh
like what sport sports
yes yes yes he played yeah he played
basketball okay
so here's where i really struggle with
that analogy with um
like
athletes especially those who
any athlete any of them but especially
those who play sports like with balls
like football or basketball
is you get really intense in those
moments and everything lasers down
to repetition
and practice
and precision
and so when i hear athletes especially
former athletes especially former
athlete dads who can't let it go and are
trying to abuse their children
through their own
wacko filter
i don't buy the argument because when
those folks lasered down
they were able to follow the play and
get a layup
they were able to
slide their feet in their just the right
way
to stan to
prevent the penetration from the top of
the key and to cause them to kick that
ball out and at the same time they're
already pivoting their body because that
that five is coming across the middle
right he knows all those things
and so either he chooses to be out of
control madness with his family
or he chooses to be in control
and he proved it for year after year
after year on the court and he's chosen
to not put that same level of effort and
care and love into his family that's why
that's unacceptable that's why i don't
buy it
and your family deserves that level of
intensity and care
and energy and practice
not running a pseudo boot camp for
future former athletes who are going to
grow up and man maybe he'll go to
college great
i gotta talk to you guys
stay way far from y'all
if your marriage even makes it that long
and here and i know i'm being hard
normally i'm not hard like this on the
show
i get real defensive of children
and i know you do too and so i'm
speaking with you here but you're real
defensive of children
and i
don't know the ins and outs of your
marriage but it sounds like there is a
nuclear reactor between the two of you
and it is slowly starting to leak out
all over the people that you all care
about and love
tell me i'm wrong or
what do you think
yeah that's
i mean you're not wrong he sounds like a
caged animal like somebody who feels
trapped
yeah i mean you feel caged too but
so what's your way forward
we wanted to be together i mean i i
wanted to be where
there's
you know balance um
with
with our family unit with the boys
activities with us
um
and it's it's almost like it's it's
getting
kind of
in our counseling and so that we talked
about you know rules and things like
that and how what i could bring and what
he brings and
you know we're two very different people
like i like you know outdoor adventures
and i like you know going to the lake
and hiking and stuff like that and and
um you know pulling that into the family
so we can all experience that and it's
almost like that part of
of you know what we had when they were
younger is just being like suffocated
because of
the sports and the day in and day out
and it's like
you know
it's it's just getting to the point
where it's really difficult to even
propose to do something like that
because there literally is no time right
and so so i want you to
in in desperate fashion quickly
you all have to create a world where
sports is not the center of your
universe
and you and your husband got some great
things from athletics i did too
really great things
and i got a lot of baggage from it too
it's both hands it's good and bad
and what i had to do and i have to do
because i've got a young son who's a
stud
he's got um physical attributes that i
never had
and when i say stud i mean like freaking
nature good
and i have had to
learn to laugh at practice
do you know what i do sometimes i take a
book to practice
not to not plug in but so that i make
sure i stay unplugged
because i have to remember he's just
playing with his buddies and he's 11.
there's no scholarships getting handed
out today
and i'd much rather him learn what
accountability is for a team so here's
my rules
are you going to play
not you have to and if you don't then
we're going to have some we're going to
do some exercises and movement here at
the house
my wife picks him up and they go for
runs now because we're in between
seasons and i didn't make him i wanted
him to do wrestling so bad i wanted him
to do it so bad because i know he'd be
good for him and he didn't want to
and so he i didn't make him
but we're still doing stuff but we're
doing it as a family and my wife's like
you she likes to be outside so they go
running after school together and it's
they have a blast together and they're
they are he's gonna have to do stuff so
i'm not just saying to do nothing
if he commits to a team there's no
quitting for that season because he
committed to a team even though it's
uncomfortable even when he has to miss
sleepovers so we're all about
accountability
and he gets to learn if you don't if you
stay up all night and eat garbage and
don't practice hard then you probably
lose that's what happens
and that's where the accountability
comes in not from me screaming like a
lunatic in the car
and i can talk to him and say hey tell
me about that game where do you think
that loss came from and he can he'll be
able to articulate it well i didn't
really
put the time in on the front end
awesome
how can i serve you how can i help
you know moving forward well be cool we
just play catch great you know what i
mean so there's ways to get at the
accountability without
brute force and childhood screaming
but at the end of the day
here's where we're at
you've got some real hard conversations
to have
and
if i'm you
i would you've got a lot do i protect my
boys do i protect myself do i save my
marriage i got a husband who's
struggling you got a lot going on
so if i'm you i'm making a call to a
counselor today for me
because you got to pull these things
apart and get some action plans
action plan number one is
whether it's a letter or it's a direct
conversation with husband you will not
yell at my boys like that again i need
that to be loud and clear and if this
happens again
i'm gonna withdraw them from the
basketball team they will not play
and if any part of that conversation
imagining that conversation makes you
feel unsafe like you're going to get
hurt you're going to get kicked out
you've got to deal with that asap
and it needs to be very clear you will
not yell at my boys
that's not motivating that's not helpful
it's none of those things i'm making
them tough it's none of those things
nonsense
nonsense they're not in the military
military hold different build different
ballgame
and then you got to get serious about do
you want to save your marriage
because your trajectory on your marriage
is not good
his behavior is that of a caged animal
and it ends poorly
poorly poorly poorly poorly poorly
and if he wants to call a show i'd love
to talk to him too
but your boys need you
because they're going to remember back
and remember dad was out of control with
rage and mom just sat there and watched
it and sarah i know you love those boys
i know that's scary and i want you to
resolve that never happens again
never happens again
[Music]
got a long road ahead of you and we're
here with you sister call me anytime i
can help and those are hard hard hard
i'll be right back on the dr john de
leon's show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple-a loan
200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we've got the follow up email
from mary from tyler texas this original
call aired on november
10th
of 2021 so if you want to go back and
listen to the original one check it out
here's what she writes back
i was recently on with and talked about
my husband
that continuously cheats on me
after hearing dr lone's advice out loud
directed straight to me i knew it was
time to leave the marriage
now on a pause right there
one of my core rules i will never tell
somebody unless they are in a
dangerous physically abusive or their
kids being abused relationship to leave
i will point a mirror back at you and
say is this the relationship you want to
be in but often and this is for all of
us especially you health professionals
and therapy therapists that listen to
the show
people will interpret what you say as a
directive so always be wise about what
you say and again she heard me say
uh you should leave your marriage
she goes on to say that evening i told
my husband i wanted a divorce
what i thought would be a night of
heartache and crying was actually one of
the best nights of my life
it felt so
freeing
capital letters
i knew for years i needed to end the
marriage but my but used my kids as a
reason to stay dr daloni opened my eyes
when he told me i was hurting my kids by
staying because they were absorbing a
toxic relationship
since i made the actions to file for
divorce i've not given it a second
thought i never realized the amount of
weight that marriage had on me i feel
like myself again
i i can breathe smile and just feel good
thank you dr daloni you truly changed my
life and gave me a whole new life before
talking to you i dreaded going to home
after work because i never knew what to
face now i leave work to go to my happy
place and i'm at peace thank you
mary
i didn't do anything
you did
you had the hard conversation you looked
in the mirror and said i'm worth more
than somebody who cheats on me all the
time my kids are worth more than this
example of what love looks like and
parenthood looks like and responsibility
and what a man looks like
my kids deserve more than that we all do
and i love how you articulated this it's
so great
most of us go home
and we don't ever
i'll say most of us that's that i said
that kind of weird
millions of people go home and they just
think that home is a place where
you might get yelled at
where your heart's supposed to beat
faster as you walk in the door not a
place of
deep exhale
and we can create homes where we can't
wait to get there where they smell good
and they feel good and everyone's
excited when people show up but that
means we gotta do with our crap
and now mary she gets to leave work and
go to her happy place which is
home
it's where she has peace
she says thank you dr deloney no mary
thank you for demonstrating courage and
strength again i love these follow-up
emails if you got good ones if you got
bad ones you think the only that was the
worst advice ever i followed it and
you're an idiot hey write back to us
johndaloni.comask you can fill it up and
it will go into the form for kelly i
love getting these follow-up emails so
go check out that original call on
november 10th and then
man
good for you mary good for you
i'm gonna continue thinking about you on
this journey you're on all right
we wrap up today's
show
man
i know there's a lot of controversy here
but nas is one of the best good folks
and off the lost tapes 2 record in 2019
the song is no bad energy and it goes
like this
i'm oblivious to you skeptics what you
hear ain't ever
yeah let me do that again sorry
i'm oblivious to you skeptics what you
hear you ain't ever hear until i rep it
iridescent hero's essence please clear
the exits i chase demons outdoors force
them to hear the message air amount
heard some people discussing my
whereabouts yeah it's been a few
sightings of me a fair amount never seen
much but yet i'm never in the house
moving style wild exciting when i do
step out you all be
you all been rhyming for years and
jungle made a hit uchiwali ideas sold a
million records had him embarrassed
signed to colombia blew a check he was
laughing while y'all in the studio
bragging about your past and thinking
back on trips on manhattan dad was
rolling hotels like the plaza black bell
ops holding rich people's bags tipped
their hats old men coming out of cabs
limousine holding doors for them we all
got a job to do go for it no bad energy
please
no bad energy just try to be the best
you man that's all i can say man
just no bad energy nahs bringing it
right here on the dr john dolone's show
you